c'est ici au berlinale palast que se
fera l'ouverture d'un festival qui
accueillera près de trois mille cinq
cents journalistes tous les projecteurs
seront braqués sur le réalisateur
philippe falardeau et son film my soul
en juillet est présenté en première
mondiale
je suis content pour le film parce que
ça va nous permettre de le positionner
devant nos états unis je suis content si
pour les deux interprètes féminines
c'est une occasion de tapis rouge quand
on fait une ouverture de festival la
berlinale est un des festivals les plus
importants au monde et présentera lors
de sa 70e édition près de 400 films
cette année c'est du jamais vu
quand l'événement accueille seize
projets canadiens dont sept
courts-métrages ici ce long métrage dont
la déesse des mouches à feu d'anaïs
barbeau-lavalette rosé très hâte suis
très fier c'est sûr que je fais briller
l'on s'en va avec une grande partie de
l'équipe le fait de présenter la bo
avant même de l'avoir présenté à la
majeure partie de l'équipe c'est quand
même le grand vertige vient de là et
pour la toute première fois
la berlinale a choisi de présenter en
première mondiale une série télévisée
d'ici c'est comme ça que je t'aime
le nouveau projet de françois létourneau
et jean-françois rivard les créateurs de
séries noires et des invincibles s'en
tape dans le dos pour nos créateurs
s'adaptant d'eau pour notre télévision
parce que c'est vrai que d'être choisi
parmi
tous les toutes les séries soumises et
d'être parmi les huit sélectionnés
c'est une bonne façon d'avoir d'avoir
une fenêtre pour montrer notre talent à
travers le monde le québec a souvent
triomphé à la berlinale
qu'on pense à quesnoy yens avec son film
rebelle fait les falardeau le picard et
geneviève du luth de sel ont aussi
chacun par le passé remporté le prix du
meilleur film dans la catégorie
génération cas plus le réalisateur denis
côté est un abonné du festival au fil
des années l'intérêt pour le cinéma
canadien le cinéma québécois s'est
précisée et plusieurs années par exemple
léa pool mais ces dernières années
davantage d'ouverture dans toutes les
sections tandis que les vedettes
défileront sur le tapis rouge qui se
trouve derrière moi la berlinale c'est
aussi l'occasion de brasser des affaires
pour les producteurs qui veulent vendre
leurs projets à l'international
on organise des rencontres de entre
producteurs pour d'éventuels
coproduction on est seize producteurs
qui ont appliqué notre programme en
terminant parlons des spectateurs car la
berlinale est un festival populaire au
cours des deux prochaines semaines près
de trois cent mille billets seront
vendus à des berlinois curieux de voir
des films des quatre coins du globe
une belle occasion pour les films
canadiens de se faire voir ici douchez
depuis mai radio-canada berlin